si en las próximas semanas viajará este
grupo de alto nivel después de que
precisamente Hoy acá en Washington se
aprobara la moción para tratar de
respaldar tratar de respetar el orden
constitucional y el estado de derecho
serán los delegados de los países
miembros de la Organización de Estados
Americanos los que viajen a Perú para
analizar la situación política del país
pero hay que escoger este grupo esto
podrá demorar algunas semanas una vez
retorne ese grupo de su viaje en Perú
tendrán que preparar un informe y
presentarlo ante el consejo permanente
es como una mirada neutral calificó el
canciller de Perú Carlos Landa este
viaje que harán los agregados de la oea
a Perú y hay que rescatar y Resaltar que
pues este viaje es diferente al que hizo
hace unas semanas la Comisión
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos